لليوم الخامس على التوالي الصين مكمل في
تسجيل عدد اصابات قياسيه بكرونا يعني خبر
حقيقه بيحسس الواحد انه يرجع لي 20 20
الله لا يعيدها طبعا من ايام لكن لا يخفى
على احد انه في موجه جديده من زياده
الاصابات للصين وامس الاصابات اليوم
1300 وشويه الصين ومن وقت ما بدات ترصد
زياده في الاصابات رجعت شددت قيودها
والسين زي ما كلنا يعني خلص صرنا نعرف
بتتبع سياسه صفر كوفت ومن وقت ما رجعت
القيود الجديده وناس كثير غضبانه وما
عادتش جديده الغضب زاد اكثر واكثر التوضيح
بس يسعد صفر
قعدت صينيين في بيوتهم اول مظاهر الفيروس
اربعه شهور كاملين ومعناها انه الصين لما
بترصد حاله واحده بس على طول بتعلن حاله
الطوارئ وبتشدد اجراءات كثير ناس ممكن
يعتبروها مالها داعي وبنتكلم نحن عن حجر
في مؤسسي همم وطلبت فرصه سلبيه يوميه
للدخول للاماكن العامه واغلاق اماكن
العامه على اللي فيها عند رصد حاله وغيرها
كمان من تدابير غضب صينيين من هذه القيود
بلغيه يعني صراحه اوجه الساعات الماضيه
وشفنا الالاف في الشوارع في مظاهرات انه
تخلل بعض هذه المظاهرات حتى شغب وعنف بكين
وشن هاي ووهان وغيرها
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
تمام
لكنها اكدت على تمسكها بالسياسه صفر كوفد
الصارمه بعض القيود المخففه مثلا انه ما
راح يحطوا بوابات لمنع الوصول للمجمعات
السكنيه اللي اكتشف فيها اصابته المظاهرات
ضد تذكرون هذه عملت اجمل الصين في
بريطانيا فهيئه الاذاعه البريطانيه البي
بي سي طلعت بيان اتهمت في الشرطه الصينيه
بالاعتداء على احد الصح فيها المعتمدين
واسمه ادوارد لورانس واعتقاله وقالت في
البيان انه الشرطه الصينيه اعتقلت قد
وحتتجزته لساعات اثناء عملوا في تغذيه
الاحتجاجات في شانه هاي وبعدين افرجت عنه
بساعات وخلال احتجاز تم ضربه وركله من قبل
الشرطه وقالت بي بي سي انه ما جاء لها اي
تفسير رسمي او اعتذار من السلطات عن اللي
صار وانه الشيء الوحيد اللي قال لهم كان
من اللي اعتقلوا الصحفي نفسه واللي قالوا
له بعد ما عنه انهم اعتقلوه لمصلحته عشان
حمايته من الاصابه بكرونا وسط الحشود يعني
محاوله جيده للافلات من الموقف بس ليش
بقول محاوله لانه ببساطه في فيديو متداول
من اعتقال الصحفي فشوفوا بالله الشرطه
الصينيه اللي خايفه عليك
هو فعلا اللي بتقول انه ما تبغى ما يخافوا
عنك او عليك ابدا طيب طبيعي انه بيان بي
بي سي قال انه حجه
كلنا خايفين على الصحفي من كرونه ما تعتبر
تفسير مناسب بالنسبه لهم ومع انتشار
الفيديو بيان بي بي سي الخارجيه الصينيه
مبررها انه الصحفي ما بلغهم انه صحفي ولا
طلع بطاقته
اوغندا
همم
الجماعه بيقولوا ما عرف عن نفسه طيب ماشي
الحال يعني لو ما كان صحفي وكان بني ادم
مواطن عادي عادي ينعمل فيه كده اسئله
كثيره تترحم لهذا الموضوع